this is a real job it's not you know
you're playing a game but it's
[Applause]
Bogey's foul on top of it depends
recount
he got Kenny the jet Smith picking the
10 grand he was doing the family
the dunk contest the sneak peek and ooh
man Garos in shop does it go Valanciunas
trying to keep it alive and unable to
grab it Levine on a cross over in the
lane
in the slam well he got Terrence Ross
that time Ross reached in get him out in
the open court t Ross
Geordi better check finally
[Applause]
we'll be coast to coast
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
the basketball being gathered he just
Sylvain the scene if there was a scene
where the sea farted Zach Lavine
that's a package a wooden package of TNT
right there he shook the rim rattled the
backboard and they tied up the rebound
told me
get up for that done that dropped out
the ceiling on that one
put it off she said a chip it's easily
exactly dropped from the ceiling
[Applause]
I don't think he's gonna miss that
pillar
Taco Bell fan spotlight he had a chance
to [ __ ] that one back it was thrown so
perfect take it down you don't want them
to get in transition Zach Lavine right
here with a Boston pirate just with a
little setup as he bounced it in there
Levine intercepts eat take septic
distances at duck chats shirt off
he sniffs anon gets off the wagon
intercepts tomography clear attempt to
catch it he throws at home it's our live
mas hysteria moment presented behind
Taco Bell well that's it
that's definitely poster material right
there get a couple guys at that post you
got John Wall to Zeller
what's a timeout after that momentum
here in Charlotte it's down to a 12
point never seen Zach will be great
anticipation he's got an open floor
problem and knows what to do with it
delivery of the game presented by Jimmy
Jones I'm noticing a trend here zach
lavine seems to be the freaky fast
delivery of the game quite often
[Applause]
just zach lavine whoa
just climb the ladder on Alex land and
that Rubio taken the basketball away a
bit watch this go jab step and he slings
it on Alex Lynn that is impressive
[Applause]
man what didn't leave his bed for a
couple of days just kind of sheltered
himself because he was worried about
what everybody was gonna say exactly
ravine with the dunk but it's still an
11 point deficit maybe he was gonna get
a whistle
[Applause]
[Applause]
no heartless
nobody picks him up so
he's cleared for takeoff
clear skies no children it's exactly the
thunder like their minutes at snapping
that rim down a little bit and that was
how he found his way into the
organization they liked it
exactly you gotta like that mad boys
free and show you how much young talent
Minnesota's been able to accumulate Zach
Lavine is one of those just rare
athletes that has the ability to show he
goes right but stop it Sampson did you
not get the memo
goodness watch this oh why Sampson why
and then committed the foul I think he
didn't remember zach lavine was a dunk
contest winner look at Samson Samson
I've said you know you get dumped on you
want to push somebody oh yeah you were
late getting over there but early for a
poster where's my poster machine down
five and his 15 in the game clock Lavine
so karl-anthony towns on this a hole
ripped the clothes out
[Applause]
P he's solidly very mature that's what
you want to see right there the stoppage
after Lavigne steal and dunk
[Music]
and wall - no one rolled to the basket
everybody was at the three-point line
Showtime Levine who and he thought he
was fouled - as he went by fast break
replay labeed on the move look at that
speed the open court trying to find
window Carter jr. in the post
meet me at the rim and don't be late
[Applause]
and after the poked away and he was
flying those nice
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what they need to get this team
going take our time by just one takeoff
time flight eight games Johnson dope six
tops so you get yourself back in again
Zach will be dumped on the dead run one
dribble and then the hammer board
inviting you to visit your local pork
store we stopped down a second trip
Archie the active dog
[Applause]
[Music]
that was basically Phatak dunk
the two guards zach lavine says you know
what get out my way there broadcasters
[Applause]
midair and hammered it down and one
motion just how you play Wow
picture-perfect pass what motion starts
at the akka no fighting hard about the
glass
[Applause]
whatever take that puppy you learn here
it is the drive right here now Selden up
there
throws it upstairs only two people who
go up there and get that you even read
the cards the basics off the dribble no
one is there to help that's very rare
you see I was going to say no one come
and challenge that for Boston
the crossover love ended up get out the
rake rake young being turned a corner
Sid blocked that one
Scott was wild spit got into the lane
though couldn't caress it home rebound
[Applause]
what a ridiculous highway Custer how do
you do it save a play give yourself an
advantage